good afternoon and welcome it is a
pleasure to welcome you to the columbia
world leaders forum we are joined today
by sebastian pinera the President of the
Republic of Chile who will speak about
chilis way of development I would like
to begin by acknowledging the presence
here today of a number of distinguished
ministers ambassadors and other members
of the Chilean delegation a warm
Colombia welcome to you all this week
heads of state from around the world are
here in New York City for the United
Nations General Assembly and we at
Columbia are delighted to welcome
several of these leaders to campus the
world leaders forum was founded in 2003
by University President Lee Bollinger to
support robust dialogue on the most
pressing issues facing our global
society it is an opportunity that would
be difficult if not impossible to
duplicate in any other city or any other
university Columbia has always been
among the most international of
institutions in the most global of
American cities with a large and growing
percentage of our students and faculty
drawn from foreign nations our academic
mission demands a global perspective and
discussions like the one we're about to
have today are a connors cornerstone of
this pursuit to further that global
perspective we have also spent the last
four years creating a global network a
network of global centers in eight
cities around the globe including
santiago de chile whose center opened in
march two thousand twelve this Columbia
global center is among our most active
and engaged under the able direction of
former minister Karen pony aah chak
there are already more than 93 Chilean
students study in Colombia 93 to be
precise some of our most distinguished
faculty were born in Chile but there
aren't enough of either a growing number
of Columbia students and faculty in all
fields are now discovering Chile Thank
You mr. president for making this
possible our colleagues have already
been discovering new paths
Columbia School of Journalism recently
announced a partnership with instituto
de la comunicacion imagine of the
universidade chili Colombia's Earth
Institute is already collaborating with
UNESCO and colleagues in Chile on a
project to manage water and an arid part
of the country students from our School
of International and public affairs have
been conducting field studies with
chilean mining companies and columbia
business school students have recently
visited the COTS a fruit processing
plant to learn about to lase exemplary
business practices president piñera a
native of santiago is a harvard-trained
economist a successful businessman and a
former senator in 2010 he became Chile's
first conservative president since
military rule ended in 1990 he has
tackled many challenges during his
presidency including including
reconstruction following one of the most
devastating earthquakes in Chile's
history and the now famous rescue of the
trapped miners near copiapó president
piñera is leading a country which marked
its own sombre commemoration of sep
tember 11th earlier this month on the
40th anniversary of the armed forces
coup in 1973 that installed a military
regime headed by army general Aldo Pinto
shed nearly a quarter century since the
restoration of democracy Chile has come
far in terms of unity human rights and
democracy and has distinguished itself
as a model for achieving sustained
economic growth echoes of the Pinochet
era still reverberate however term
limits prevent president venir after I'm
running for re-election this year
although nobody is ruling out future
years the leading candidates competing
to replace him have captured the world's
attention with a gripping story told by
their intertwined personal histories
former Chilean President Michelle
Bachelet who spoke at our world leaders
forum in 2007 is the candidate of the
centre-left she was tortured under
premio sets rule and her father a
general in the army was tortured and
killed Evelyn Matai is a member of the
center-right coalition whose far
was a leading figure in the military
regime they represent along with
president piñera a generation of leaders
who have come to the center of Chile's
political stage long after penis its
departure but who nonetheless continue
to confront issues informed by the
nation's authoritarian past whoever
emerges as the next president of chile
will be leading a country that is now
acclaimed for its growth productive
workforce and transparent institutions
yet like many nations it is a country
with an alarming gap dividing the rich
and the poor earlier this year president
piñera explained that the key who had
eradicated poverty and establishing
Chile as a developed nation will be for
the country to grow grow around six
percent not over one two or three years
but many more this insightful and
truthful comment is reflective of his
tenure as president of chile a tenured
that has been marked by willingness to
squarely face difficult problems and
then present solutions in a
straightforward and unvarnished manner
I'm now very pleased to invite president
sebastián piñera to the stage to share
more of his ideas on chilles way of
development thank you very much
thank you very much for your kind words
and as president of chile i'm very happy
and enthusiastic because we have just
signed a cooperation agreement with
Colombia University which will add up to
the agreements that we already have with
Berkeley MIT and Harvard which are among
the best universities in the world and
this is part of our commitment with
knowledge with science with technology
Tilly was the poorest Spanish colony in
the end of the world separated from the
world with by the driest deserts the
biggest ocean the highest mountain and
the South Pole but despite that we have
managed to become now the country with
the highest per capita income in Latin
America but that's not enough because we
are fully aware that the mission that we
have to accomplish is to transform chile
before the end of this decade so so it's
a very short challenge and go into a
developed country without poverty with
more equality of opportunities and
that's the mission of our generation we
have just celebrated our Bicentennial
there are very few countries among them
the u.s. that have been able to
celebrate their bicentennial scenes as
an independent state so I would like to
share with you my views and some facts
and evidence about what has been called
the Chilean path to development first of
all if you take a look at how the
worldwide GDP and population has evolved
in the last two thousand and years you
see that nothing happened or very little
happened between the times of cleopatra
and marc antonio and the times of
napoleon but at that time a big change
started to occur
as you see in the 19th century and
particularly in the 20th century the
world radically changed and this is
basically due to the what was called the
Industrial Revolution at that time life
expectancy almost double in a few
decades a few decades but more important
than that you see how the evolution of
world population and world GDP started
to grow very very fast in general the
past century the 20th century we saw a
huge explosion in our capacity to create
but also a huge explosion in our
capacity to destroy it was a century
that witnesses the moment man took his
first step on the moon but also we saw
the emergence of man's capacity to
destroy the world several times and the
century that witnesses the worst and
most cruel words like was the first and
the second world war but despite that
the evolution of GDP and also devolution
of population and economic growth during
this period was very very uneven you can
see in this graph that some countries
were able to take advantage of the
Industrial Revolution mainly the United
States Western Europe Japan and that's
it the rest of the world lacked behind
Latin America which is a past and
fertile I'm very extremely rich in
natural resources a continent that did
not experience the two world wars as the
Europe that has not suffered the
religious conflicts that have led people
to kill each other in the name of the
same God as happened in Europe that has
not had the radical come the rush of
conflicts that the colonization of
Africa left behind in other words Latin
America has always had everything to
reach development and yet
has not yet taken advantage of all this
opportunity and this is something that
we want to change but in the past 20
years not only the world has changed
first the Berlin Wall fell brillig ating
communists only to Cuba and North Korea
but at the same time something more at
all astonishes happen the center of the
world began to move eastward until it
went from a forgotten corner at the
bottom of the world known as they finish
terror to face the ocean of the future
the oath the ocean on which the eyes of
three quarters of the population are set
and I'm talking about the Pacific Ocean
nowadays the world is conversion with
few exceptions we are looking at the
second wave or modernization that no
words can hold back it is this new world
of technology and information that has
given a second chance to those countries
that didn't took advantage of the first
chance which was the Industrial
Revolution to reach development and to
integrate itself to what is called the
first world let's see how the world is
evolving now the emerging economies
begin to gain ground vasavi the
developed world you can see here the
participation of the share of total gdp
by developed countries and emerging
economies and today is basically a tie
fifty fifty percent which was not the
case only 20 years ago especially China
and India the giant the Asian giants are
recovering the place that they used to
have in the world and that they lost and
you can see how they are representing a
bigger and bigger percentage of the
world total economy the emerging
countries are recovering much faster
than the developed world after the
financial crisis of 2008
and you can see here how the recovery of
the growth rate of different countries
defers especially between developed and
developing countries GDP projection by
region shows that if everything
continues as it is China will become the
largest economy by the year 2013 2025
and 2030 and I will imply a major change
in the political economic and social
structures of the world now coming back
to Tilly in 2010 we celebrated our 200
years of independence here you have a
picture with the five presidents that
are still alive and we joined together
to celebrate these Bicentennial and now
we want to make another state to take
another step a giant step towards
development and defeating poverty and
for that is good to ask us how well we
have done or how poorly we have done and
the answer to that question depends with
whom we compare ourselves if we compare
yourself with the world we Latin America
Chile has done a very good job
particularly as you can see there in the
last 30 years when we started to grow
much faster than the rest of the region
and that's why we were able to move from
one of the lowest position in terms of
per capita income to the first position
in terms of per capita Inc but by that
standard the discount which was so
isolated decided at a given point in
time to integrate to the world and right
now Chile has free trade agreement with
more than 60 countries around the world
among than the US China Europe India
Japan Korea you name it so basically
this small country which it was in the
end of the world the finished era is now
a country which is willing
to strength is its integration to the
world if we compare yourself with Latin
America you see that Chile was among the
lowest per capita income in the region
and now has become the country with the
highest per capita income in the country
and probably the country with the best
opportunity to become a developed
country and to defeat poverty before the
end of this decade because you had to
put a date in order to transform it's a
dream into a project into a real
commitment in terms of comparing chili
with the rest of the world you see that
for a long period of time it was a kind
of time then we lost I will lag behind
but we have been able to recover and we
are growing much faster than the rest of
the world and therefore we are moving in
the right direction right now chili is
in a position with a 20,000 per capita
income to catch up some European
countries like Portugal or Greece or or
or including and other countries if we
keep growing at six percent we are part
of the OECD and therefore our task is
not just to do better than other Latin
American countries that were real
mission is to become a developed country
in all the real meaning of that world
but if we compare yourself with the best
you see that except for the last three
years we also have been lagging behind
he is a comparison between the OECD
countries until the question is what is
what we need to have to achieve before
the end of this take what is the mission
of the generation of the Bicentennial
which is our responsibility and
basically our mission is a very
ambitious one a very novel won a very
demanding one but we think that is also
an achiever one which is basically to
transform till it into a country without
poverty and with real opportunities for
everybody and to overcome and the
develop
this we know is a huge challenge which
was the dream of our fathers I will
grandfather's they always cherish this
accomplishment but they never were able
to achieve it and we hope that we were
able to change that history this is the
challenge with which our government came
to power three years ago and for that of
course we will need to change history
and to take advantage of all the
potentialities of this small country in
the end of the world very close to the
South Pole so I want to talk about the
future the difference between the future
and the past is only one the past is
already written we can talk about it for
years but we can look and we cannot
change a comma about it but the future
is something very deep it is not written
and therefore we can dip our pants into
ink and begin to write it and that's
basically what we want to do how first
of all we are fully aware of the
importance of what has been called the
old pillars of development a stable
democracy that would have it remember
that Chile had been always almost always
a very stable democracy scenes that were
independent except for a couple of
interruptions the last one as was
mentioned was in 1973 when I could data
and the Democratic period and started a
military regime but we were able to
recover our democracy in 1988 and 88 89
together with the fall of the Berlin
Wall and the Iron Curtain and we will
stand in a very wise way normally
transitions from a military government
to democratic government occurs in the
mill of political crisis economic cows
and social violence this was not the
case of teeth because we learned from
our mistake and we were able to reach a
very deep and broad agreement in order
to pace the way to the recuperation of
our democracy and therefore we need to
strength the old tradition
pillars stable democracy and rule of law
expect a social responsible open market
economy and unaffected state in the
search of social justice but we are
fully aware that that is necessary but
it's not sufficient in order to become a
developed country we need to avoid what
has been called the middle income trap
of developing countries history has
shown us that these three pillars are
not enough anymore in the 60s there were
many middle-income countries that wanted
to become developed countries and many
fell into what has been called the
middle income trap let us recall the 80s
and 90s when many economies especially
those from Latin America suffered from
stagnation and turbulence for almost 20
years and only a handful managed to move
from under development to develop among
them you can name Japan Singapore South
Korea Taiwan Hong Kong and that's it
that's why the transit or the evolution
of the transition from under development
to develop has never been easy and the
best proof of that that only bunch of
country have been able to accomplish
that goal Mountaineers know very well
that the second half of the essence to
the summit is definitely the most
beautiful but we are very much aware
that is also the most difficult and the
toughest one that's why until it we are
trying to build or to strength the new
pillars of development and I just want
to mention them but the first one is
that we need to dramatically change the
quality of our human capital that means
that we need to change and reform our
educational system and our training
system that's why we are so enthusiastic
about this agreement that we have with
the Columbia University but because we
are sure that you can
be a very good partner in this challenge
the second thing is that we want to
develop triple our investment in science
and technology to become part of this
society of knowledge and information the
third pillar is that we need to boost
innovation and entrepreneurship which is
mainly of basically the most important
renewable resource that we do have to
attack this challenge and this effort
towards development we need to modernize
our state particularly in a world which
is so dynamic and it's changing so
rapidly we need a very flexible state in
order to be able to adapt and take
advantage of the opportunity and finally
and this is a very important task we're
convinced that we need to defeat poverty
and we need to reduce extreme
inequalities and create a society with
more equality of opportunities those are
the five new pillars in which we are
working very hard and with which we are
one hundred percent committed how it is
moving basically this was set up in our
government program which had a special
chapter for each of these new challenges
we committed herself to double our
capacity to growth from three percent
which was the average of their former
government to six percent which was our
target at the same time we committed
ourselves to create 1 million jobs in a
four year period that's equivalent if we
compared with us with a target of 20
million jobs in four years in order to
get rid of unemployment and reach a
situation of full employment the third
goal was to eradicate extreme poverty to
improve the quality of education to
improve the quality of the health system
to reduce crime and drug trafficking and
to modernize the state and strengthen
our democracy those were the seven main
commitment that we made during our
campaign and of course during the
campaign you commit yourself when you
are
in government you have to fulfill and
comply with your commitments how are
things going first of all why we needed
to grow a six percent for many reasons
first of all because that was the
necessary growth rate in order to become
a developed country and I achieve a per
capita income of twenty-four thousand
dollars which is above what do they have
countries like Portugal greens are many
other Europeans and we were aware that
for that we needed to increase
substantially our capacity to grow in
the first three years our average growth
has been five point papers and despite
many difficulties one of the difficulty
was already mentioned 11 days before we
took office the fifth worst earthquake
and tsunami in the known history of
mankind hit our country and it was a
devastating one it destroyed one out of
every three schools one out of every
three hospital thousand of roads bridges
airports ports infrastructure the total
bill at the end of the day after a few
minutes we had lost in a few minutes
almost twenty percent of our GNP in
terms of destroy infrastructure and that
happen only a few days before we took
office but that was not the only
difficulty the other difficulty was that
the world has been in a permanent crisis
since then it started in 2008 and you
know that very well because maybe this
serious own was right here in New York
and it hasn't yet ended and that was the
second difficulty that we had to face
and address the third one was that the
country that we received was losing its
capacity to grow and create jobs and
increase productivity and improve
salaries and increase investment and
therefore we had to change the tide and
that's something which you know very
well is never easy but those were the
main difficulties
what has been the results basically we
can distinguish three periods in the
last part of our economic history the
first is between 86 and 97 where we
behave as a hair the growth rate was
above seven percent relativity was
increasing in a very substantial way
creation of new jobs was was very strong
and we were growing much faster than the
rest of the world unfortunately
something happened in the late 90s
because from 1998 to 2009 2009 another
12 year period we behaved as tortoise
because the growth rate went down by
half the same thing happened with
productivity and job creation and we
were growing at a lesser path than the
rest of the world as can be seen in this
graph so why were commitment was to
recover that leadership that dynamism
because it was absolutely necessary to
achieve our goal to become a developed
country without poverty before the end
of the decade and therefore in the last
three years Chile has recovered its
leadership we went from what was called
the cheetah miracle to the Italian up
this is something that was established
by the by a very famous magazine called
economist and now we are recovering that
dynamism and that leadership which is
absolutely necessary to achieve our
goals but if we keep growing a six
percent per year which was has been
basically we have done in the last three
years we will be able to become a
developed country before the end of this
decade by achieving a 24,000 per capita
income level which is the treasurer of
the separates according to the World
Bank the developed world from the
developing world that's why we are
working in this direction you can see
that already we have jumped many places
in terms of the ranking of her capita
income and we are not only in the first
place in Latin America but we are also a
over passing some European countries and
we need to keep growing and did pay
added pace to achieve our goal but we
have a lot of strength in order to
achieve this goal for instance here we
have some economic and human development
indices which are basically serve a
established by the World Bank by the UN
by the economic world forum and you can
see that if you compare chill in terms
of human development index or economic
freedom index or is to doing business
index or global competitors in index we
are to some extent closer to the average
of the OECD country than to the average
of the Latin American countries and
that's a very strong base in order to
start and address this huge challenge of
changing where has been our history for
the last 200 years the same thing if we
take other in the sex which measure
quality of institutions like rule of law
political stability and others you see
that in this indices which are
international indexes again chilis
prepared to undertake this new jam big
jump in order to become a developed
country now with respect to the
integration to the rest of the world
here you have a map in which are shown
all the countries with which we have
free trade agreements you can see that
we have free trade agreements with North
America with Latin America with Europe
with China with Japan with Korea with
India and therefore we are very well
prepared to take advantage of this new
global world which is emerging under our
eyes and we are also working in new
initiative one of them is the TPP the
trans-pacific partnership in which we
are partners with the US and if we are
able to accomplish this goal the target
of the date was the end of this year in
our next epic epic meeting in
bally it would become the largest free
trade zone in the world it started with
four countries brunei singapore New
Zealand and Chile and now we are 12
members because the US Canada and Japan
have joined in and therefore that's one
of the most important initiative in
which we are working on to enlarge this
free trade zone of the asia-pacific the
second ish initiative is the Pacific
Alliance which is an alliance which is
very new very very done it was signed
only one year ago until it in a place
which is called perunnal when we have
the one of the largest observatories to
see and watch the skies and the stars
but in one year it has been extremely
fruitful right now we do have a free
trade agreement between the four
countries which literally liberalize it
has liberalized tariffs for more than
ninety percent of the good and services
are being trade between this country but
it's not only trade of services and
goods it's also and into an economic
integration that takes into account
physical integration energy integration
and also free movement of people between
all these countries and we are joining
forces in order to be able to take
advantage of all the possibilities that
this new asia pacific world is offering
and is putting in front of our eyes but
what I've having the results here you
can compare what was happened in 2009
which was the last year the former
governor and what has happened in the
last three years you can see the growth
went from negative to positive and we
are a averaging almost six percent per
year unemployment went down and we are
very close to a full employment
situation in terms of job creation and
we have been able to create more than a
hundred and thirty thousand jobs in
three years and a half which is a very
is the highest job creation rate in the
history of our country the same thing
with exports we have gone up from 555
55 billion dollars to almost 80 billion
dollars and productivity and investment
of growth which have been double or
almost tripling our rate of growth of
GMP and therefore investment as a
percentage of GMP is going up that means
that we are moving in the right
direction and if we keep at this speed
and the sender direction we will be able
to achieve the the goal of becoming a
developed countries now this of course
has also to do not only with growth and
economic variables but also with the
most important thing which is improve
improving the quality of life of our
people and feel you have some indicators
in terms of different aspects for
instance in 2009 only four point eight
million people used to take vacations
summer vacation that figures has almost
doubled in three and a half years and
it's a good indicator of how the quality
of life of people you can measure it in
terms of cinema ticket souls or books
edited or travels abroad or new car
souls and so many others indicate so we
think that chili is moving in the right
direction we are fully aware that still
we will have to face many many
challenges we know that the second part
of this adventure is the most beautiful
one but it's also the most difficult one
but at the same time we are fully aware
that this is our mission is our
responsibility to do what our fathers
and grandfathers always wanted but never
accomplished and there is nothing
nothing should divert us from that goal
that's why as president of chile we can
of course be we are not of course
satisfied with what we are we have
already accomplished because always we
want to accomplish more but in a few
decades Tilly has been able to recover
its democracy which is the normal way of
life of the Chilean people and at the
same time recover its dynamism
leadership in terms of
be able to improve substantially our
capacity to grow to a jobs improve
salaries reduce poverty and if we keep
moving in the same direction and at the
same speed Chile probably will become
the first hopefully not the only one
Latin American country able to get rid
of poverty over time and the development
and integrate itself to that very
special Club of countries which have
been able to compatible eyes democracy
with development I with peace that is
our target and that's why we are so
committed and so enthusiastically
committed with this task which of course
is something that we think that we owe
not only to our people today but also to
our sons and they and the sense of our
sense because we are very grateful with
God because we have received probably
the most magnificent country in the
world thank you very much
they push my foot the floor is open now
two questions there are microphones on
each of the two aisles so if you do have
a question I urge you to go to the
microphone and when you ask your
question please let us know who you are
and try to keep your questions brief
over here my name is Sarah free I
studied abroad in Chile a while ago but
president piñera as the first
democratically elected center-right
president after the transition what
would you consider your greatest
accomplishment as president thank you
Sarah i would say three things first of
all to be able to reconstruct our
country in four years let me tell you a
little story I met with the Prime
Minister of Japan and I asked him how
long we would take for them to
reconstruct what had been destroyed by
their earthquake and tsunami and he told
me at least 10 years and three years of
recession in our case our target was
four years to reconstruct and without
recession that's something which i think
is a very important accomplished not
only the government of course of the
Chilean people the second is to recover
our capacity to grow and to create jobs
and to innovate because that's something
that is very easy to lose and it's very
hard to recover and the third
accompanies a more emotional one and I
remember those time with a great deal of
no saji and emotion we was the search
and rescue of our 33 miners when they
were lost in the depth of the mine in
the driest desert in the world and
nobody knew where they were when they
were at a life or death but the Chilean
government had the wheel and the
commitment to look for them and honor
the commitment that I made personally
with the families I remember when I have
right there and nobody knew what was
happening I told them that we will look
for those miners asked if they were
asked if they were our own sons and I
think that we honored our committee
yes over here thank you very much for
your excellent presentation mr.
president my name is Kyle danto I'm an
undergraduate student second year
studying economics and my question for
you is that your term ends next year
after just four years due to the
constitutional law as I mentioned
earlier now in the election this year it
is the front-runner i believe is for
president bascially who as you mentioned
during the period between nineteen
nineteen ninety-seven and your election
wish you was present during saw a slower
economic growth so my question is how do
you intend to build institutions and
what programs have you put in place that
will help guarantee that that six
percent growth that you have said Alfred
chalet will continue throughout the
decade even after you are no longer
president and governments were somewhat
different views viewers might take power
thank you go well nobody can guarantee
that so we are having elections by the
end of this year and the new government
will take power in March 2014 and nobody
can guarantee that the country like
Chile would keep growing at six percent
a year so we'll be basically the
responsibility of the new government to
keep this trend and I hope that they
will realize that the most important
factor in growth is freedom freedom to
innovate freedom to start new projects
freedom to unleash all the forces that
are behind freedom and when you try to
control those forces the only thing that
you will get is stagnation so I cannot
guarantee you that nobody can guarantee
that but something that will have to be
achieved by the new government but I
hope that they will realize two things
first of all that the best way to
undertake this challenge is by
reinforcing and strengthen our
democratic system the rule of law
respect for human rights
and the second lesson is that the best
way to achieve that target is by
unleashing the tremendous forces of
freedom that lives in the heart of every
citizen in the world and particularly
lives in the hearts of every Gillian
because we have proved that when we work
in a democratic system and with unity
Chile has proved that we are able to
achieve goals that may seem impossible
for many people and we have proved that
impossible is nothing yes over here my
name is vasilis Van Dyke is some a
professor of FM by the metal engineering
at Columbia director of the center for
life cycle analysis I echo and uploaded
the message for freedom I actually grew
up in a country that was under the
military dictatorship at the same time
with a military dictatorship in Pinochet
so I'm cognizant of the difficulties and
I applaud the pathway the roadmap tobers
development I have been looking
carefully at the indicators that you
have in the terms of measure in the
development and I see it my opinion
something that is missing allow me is
energy actually in the list of
scientists like me we have energy at the
very top and that is not only for the
development of the country but also as a
citizen of the world that it is
connected both with poverty and climate
change and so many other issues and I
know that actually mining is a lot of
energy and mine is concentrating the
northern part of the country and you
have the best solar resources perhaps of
the world up there and the Atacama
Desert is very dry so you don't have a
lot of water to use it by burning coal
and LNG and I say perfect synergy there
between solar energy and they need for
increased electricity for mining and I
know that your administration brought a
law to the Congress the renewable energy
law that the Congress approved and i
think is very important for that law to
become a reality and i know that you
have political forces from the current
status work
they oppose any change so my question is
are you behind this law obviously you
are because you brought it up but what
you think of how you can overcome the
political forces that are opposing this
change getting from burning more coal
and moral energy and more diesel into
solar and wind Thank You lezim is right
you're right we didn't mention energy
doesn't mean that it's not important
actually it's a key factor in our road
or path to develop Tilly was a very poor
country in old fuels fossil fuels
wouldn't have much oil or gas but
Chilly's extremely rich in the new
sources of energy renewable clean energy
like wind energy solar energy geothermal
energy and we are trying to change the
institution and the laws in order to
enable us to take advantage of those new
sources of energy and solar is a key one
actually we are investing in a new
renewable energy more than ten times
what was the average of the past because
we are fully aware that it's a question
of time when those new sources of energy
will become economically competitive but
in Chile we have a special a special
challenge in this area because as you
said is true we have a tremendous
potential in for these new sources of
energy we have the deserts with the
highest valiant solar riders in the
world and we were having learned today
with people in pain related to the
energy sector and they are extremely
enthusiastic and optimism about what we
can do until it with these new source of
energy that's why we're exploring solar
energy wind energy geothermal energy
wave energy and we are putting a lot of
public money in order to promote because
we know that I will come and we try to
we're trying to accelerate that time in
order to have those new source of energy
right now when we need it for instance
in the northern part of the country is a
desert till it by the way Chile some
people think that it is very sick
the head is very warm and the feet are
very cold in the north of all the
country who have the desert in the south
of part of the country we have the South
Pole but things are going and looking
very promising in this respect because
the way that the technology in terms of
solar and wind energy is improving at
the past that is improving it means that
very soon it will be economically fully
competitive and when that happens wind
and solar energy will be much more
important than oil or gas poor or cold
energy until it and that would be
extremely needed for many reasons first
of all because in the north part of the
country we have more than 100 billion in
terms of investment projects that will
need energy and water and if you have
cheap energy you will be able to
digitalize tell you say that these these
are nice this align wouldn't how you say
this life water and therefore will be
able normally to produce energy but also
to dis analyze water and pump it all the
way up to the mountains where the mines
are that's why energy and water are two
key factors are normally we thought that
they were very abundant and now we
realize that we have to take good care
of them because those two may become the
most important restriction for the world
capacity to grow
that we started working with versity of
antofagasta and probably the University
of San Diago on this challenge trying to
help there put your welcome thing when
did you start it just now actually
pretty perhaps a couple of weeks ago we
have a paper ready to present to the
European food will take conference in in
Paris later this month okay and in
January actually would be in the
University of antofagasta when the first
symposium on leith humane and so on you
are most welcome come back with us in
our plane tomorrow yes Suh excelente
Afghan panera my name is Christopher Kon
and my question for you would be how
would you answer some critics who claim
that your education program your
education investment is outdated before
it even began let me tell you what we
are doing and then we might compute what
it is outdated or not first of all we
when we were running our campaign one of
the key and most important factor that
we were strengthening was that we needed
to improve the quality of education
substantial for instance with now we
have been able to guarantee access to
preschool education universally and free
for everybody that's a major change
because that's where you can make the
biggest the biggest differences because
at that time is when you can change and
you can produce real equality of
opportunities normally all the attention
was concentrating on higher education or
university university education that we
had over looked what was happening with
preschool education two three four years
when those kids particularly they belong
to poor or vulnerable families they need
to have this input in terms of the right
dedication and motivation and that's
something that we have already
accomplished now we can guarantee that
every children in Chile
free access to preschool education we
have almost increased our budget our
investment in education from nine
billion to 14 billion dollars in three
years that's the highest jump in our
investment in the occasion in our
history but also we are taking into
account what is happening with the
higher university because a university
education because that's where we have
had the most significant problems what
we have committed first of all that no
student will be left out of university
education because of lack of resources
and for that we guarantee scholarships
for every student belonging to the sixty
percent of the poorest household until
it and subsidized loan for the rest and
therefore today nobody until they can
say that he will be left or she will be
left out of higher unike education
because of lack of resources because the
government is guaranteeing that but of
course even though we're investing much
more money in terms in strategy that we
had called 3 by 3 because we are trying
to attack the three problems access
financing and quality at the three-level
preschool school and higher education
but of course we're just re and
therefore is true that where we have
done what we have accomplished up to now
is not enough even though the quality of
the children education we have been
stagnated for 20 years and I'm talking
about this international measurement
like the pizza or teams exams is finally
improving and very in a very substantial
way that's why when people think that we
can accomplish all the results in terms
improving the quality of education in
the three year period they are dreaming
they don't know what they're talking
about so somebody thinks that all the
result should be ready in three years
and because of that because we haven't
been able to reach that he thinks that
the system or what we are doing is not
the right policy I think that he doesn't
have the right evidence to conclude that
we think that why we're doing the right
thing because we are guaranteeing access
financing and quality education for
every student from preschool school and
higher education
yes over here thinking I'm johnny cowan
I'm a first year student engineering
student and with the building of the
very large telescope in Chile Chile has
had a global presence and the scientific
community what is chilly doing to
maintain this chili is very committed
with the world community we were part
founders of the United Nations that will
bang the IMS and we are product laying a
rope which is not equivalent to our size
for our economic G&P and we think that
we can and we should keep playing that
role in the international community
that's why for instance today is not
chilly now is not receiving Ellen for
air any foreign aid we have moved from
receiving to providing for eight to
other countries because we feel that
that is our responsibility but I agree
with you that for us depressants and the
commitment of Chile win the national
community and the new problems that we
will have to face together because in
the past problems were at the national
scale today that's not even that's not
more the case in order to defeat for
instance climate change terrorism or
drug trafficking we need to work
together that's why I Chile believes in
international organization even though
they have problems and Chile believes in
international cooperation because we are
fully convinced that that's the only way
to move forward in an efficient way
given the kind of problems and the
nature of the problems that we're facing
today given the follow up with the gist
mention is astronomy I I was asking
about the very large telescope in Chile
oh yeah um and how I guess chili is
going to stay ahead one science you know
that in Chile we have the clearest and
brightest skies in the world that's why
we have already become the world capital
of astronomy we have many many
international ventures which are
investing in astronomy in our country
with a few times a few months ago we
inaugurated the biggest telescope in the
world which is called Alma and we are
providing all the necessary guarantees
and facilities in order to keep moving
in that direction and transformative
whichever is the capital of astronomy in
the world in real in a real center for
research and develop and we planning to
open another telescope which will be
called the extreme large telescope that
will be able to go back in the history
of universe right now we have been able
to go back twelve thousand and three
hundred years back in the history of
university people think that the history
universe goes all the way back to twelve
thousand and seven hundred years with
this new extremely large telescope we
will be approaching or we will be
getting closer to what was called the
Big Bang which is considered the origin
of the universe and therefore we are
very enthusiastic about that we are
providing not only our skies and our
facilities but also we are investing a
lot of public and private money in
developing that area of our society
thank you yes sir when I service
excelencia my name is Joseph Francis
vecherom a first year student here at
Columbia College I was just in Chile a
month ago it's beautiful by the way I've
been there before I probably would go
there again I loved it but when I was
there I noticed there are a lot of
protests were going on regarding issues
like education and health care where the
people are demanding that the government
isn't doing enough or maybe the
government they haven't they don't know
what the government's doing one what
would be your answer to those people who
are demanding these things and what kind
of what are you putting in place for
that and my second question is your
young sheila is always comparing itself
with the rest of latin american with the
oecd countries and we can see that
there's obviously like I got growing
between Chile and the rest of Latin
America
what has your government or if your
government hasn't done much what do you
propose that the Chilean government
should do to kind of help the rest of
Latin America get to that point where
the government never do enough or never
does not do it does well the governor
never does that something which is true
has always been true and will always
been true and that applies also to your
government but i would say that
important thing is that the chili
society has changed and it's more much
more impatient is much more aware of the
rights is looking at me look at the
skies with the in terms of asking for
the best and i think that's good because
that post puts a lot of pressure on
governments to do better and to move
faster but of course if you don't
realize that you have crapped your eyes
in the skies because at the future the
hope you also have to have your feet in
the ground because that's realism but
tell me any one country where people do
not protest either it is a dictatorship
or they are not alive tilly we have the
democracy and we are very much alive yes
over here mr. president i'm melissa
martinez I'm from Mexico first-year
student at the School of International
and public affairs where are the
concrete expected benefits that will be
derived from the free transit of people
clause in the Pacific Alliance for its
members and in general for latin america
with a Pacific Alliance is a deep effort
of integration between these four
countries Mexico Colombia Peru and Chile
and one of the main issue and one of the
most difficult issues was to allow free
movement of people because when you
allow free movement of goods and service
is good when your life free movement of
capitals and you integrate your
financial markets is better when you
integrate physical your countries with
away with the energy and growth is even
better
but I think that the key question or the
key test of a real integration is when
you allow free movement of people and we
have just reached an agreement with
Mexico because with Mexico we have free
movement of people from a long time ago
but Mexico had to agree to give the same
benefits to Peruvians and Columbus and
finally they did and I hope that this
will prove that we are integrated not
only in terms of goods and services but
the most important part is integration
in terms of people so we are already
seeing a lot of students from Colombia
or Peru or Mexico Chile going to other
country to to fulfill the studies and a
lot of entrepreneurs moving from one
country to another a lot of joint
ventures although things will allow us
to join forces to be able to face the
huge challenge that we have to face in
order to be part of this new pacific
asia pacific alliance so it's so new
only one year is the age of the pacific
alliance that we have yet to measure
what will be the benefit but i tend to
anticipate or predict that a real
integration has to include free movement
of people thank you yes Senor Presidente
my name is Marisa Lorraine from Chile
I'm a professor of Finance at the
business school so I have also a
question about education so in the last
two weeks two important countries Mexico
and Brazil have implemented important
changes to their educational system
Mexico by allowing teachers to be
evaluated and reducing the power of the
teaching teachers unions and Brazil by
allocating 75% of oil revenues towards
education regarding chili what do you
think is the main reform that's missing
in order to improve the quality of our
education system many there are many
reforms that are in the process of being
implemented but basically let me tell
you what has been our main differences
with some of the leaders of the
university student movement they ask you
for two things with which I fully
disagree first of all some of them want
to get rid of private education and they
want the government or the state to
monopolize hundred percent of the
education at every level we disagree
with that because we think that that
would not only jeopardize the quality of
education but we kill freedom and
without freedom education is not now you
disagree as well we disagree as well and
therefore what we are what we are
defending is that we should have a mixed
system where we have public and private
school private and public university and
students or their parents depending on
the age of the students have the right
to decide we have not the right to take
that power decision from the students or
from the parents and that's a big
difference because if you get get rid of
private education at the end of the day
the government will monopolize education
and from there to the step where they
will try to utilize that monopoly in
terms of trying to influence people I
think that's a huge risk not only for
quality but also for freedom and
therefore we are defending a mixed
system where you have private and
private school private and public
university and we are defending the
right of students or parents to decide
to decide whether where they want to
study and what they want to stand we all
think that the government has the right
to take away that decision power from
the people that's one big difference
it's an ideological difference that's
why we say that the governor has the has
the duty to guarantee that everybody
will have access to preschool school and
higher education but we don't have the
right to take away that decision from
the students or their parents and that's
why we are defending that we will give
scholarships or loans to everybody but
we will not interfere with the decision
with respect to
and what to study that's one big
difference that has been there for the
last two years the second big difference
that we don't agree that education
should be free for everybody at every
level with no with no conditions because
Tilly is still a country has a lot of
social problems and therefore we say
that the governor will guarantee free
education at preschool and school level
but at the higher level which is the
university level we will guarantee
access and funding scholarship for sixty
percent of the students loans for the
next thirty percent and the richest ten
percent we have to pay from their own
pocket from their dedication and many of
the students are asking for free
education for everybody at every level
with no conditions and we disagree with
that too because we think that we have
so many other social problems that the
government shouldn't be channeling a
resources which are paid by the taxes of
everybody to fund the education of the
richest groups of our those are the
biggest to difference that we have with
some of the student leaders leaders and
have been in the public eye for the last
two or three years and we have not I
will not give up on any of those two
positions finally what we are doing of
course is trying to improve the quality
of education and for that we need to
improve the quality of teachers and
teachers worldwide don't like to be
measured and we have said very simple if
you don't like to be measured okay you
will stay in your system but it really
want to become part of the new system
where they will get much better salaries
and much better opportunity you need to
be avoided and if you don't pass that
exam you won't be able to access the new
system so we will have an old system and
a new system and therefore teachers will
have to make a decision if they want to
become part of the new system with much
better salaries and opportunities and
many other things
they will need to pass an exam and if
they pass it they will be eligible for
the new system that they don't they
won't and of course I don't like it so
that's another difference which was the
same discussion in Mexico I just talked
on the phone to president Pena Nieto and
he was telling me how that a fight is
going over in Mexico I will respect to
resources I am aware that Brazil has
decided to allocate a given percentage
almost seventy percent of oil to
education in our case were investing
almost twenty-five percent of public
expenditure in education one out of
every four dollars in our budget goes to
education and that's one of the highest
percentages in Latin America and one of
the highest percentages in the world
that's why we have increased our public
expenditure in education from nine
billion to 14 billion that's almost a
sixty percent increase in three years
because we're fully convinced but not to
be able to solve the three problems in
the three levels quality access and
financing at preschool school and
university education we needed to
increase the public expenditure on
education as much as necessary and by
the end of this week i will present the
budget for 2014 and again education and
health will be the two sets of with
highest increase in terms of our budget
yes mr. president my name is gustavo
game errands i am a first year student
in the CBS MA program and I'm come from
Brazil fellows all South American and
like in the last decade or so we think
there are many South American countries
Brazil Argentina they have turned into
like left to win populous countries and
why we chill in Colombia they have kept
on the sensible economic track with free
trade policies and everything and why do
you why do you give credit for Chile
keeping on the right track not falling
to the populism we're populism
is a very contagious illness agree and
if you take a look at Latin America you
will be you can prove that statement I
don't want to really to judge what other
countries are doing because we live in a
world where we have to learn to live
with our differences but of course what
we are doing in till difference the in
terms of our democratic model our
development model is very different from
what other Latin American countries are
doing and I think that that's why we are
doing it we think that at least for
Chile our model is the best one for us
and we are fully aware that populism and
violence are very strong enemies of
democracy of real democracy and are very
strong enemies of real economic
development we cannot guarantee because
we will have a lectures and you know
that we have elections candidates become
very populist and apron eyes everything
this world and the other but one of them
will be elected so my only message to
the candy that remember that one of them
will have to honor the commitments and
therefore they have to learn that they
cannot promise what they cannot fulfill
and therefore they will have to be or
there should be much more responsible
and that's something which is very
difficult to put in the ears or in the
minds of candidates because what they
say back is Luke first I have to win and
then I will be responsible but many
times you are cut with your own promises
and commitments while you were a
candidate that's why we we hope that the
the election that would take place until
I by the end of the year will not change
the path or the speed of our a
transition towards development I've been
informed that the president has other
obligations
and I'm sorry to cut off conversation so
quickly so perhaps the first two people
on each side could ask their questions
all at once one after the other and the
president will respond and I'm afraid
the rest of you that we won't have time
starting here you can send me your
questions by email no problem I'll do it
tonight yeah no no I can do you can make
it right here sure um thank you so much
I'm surprised in improving unless you
want to give you a place to somebody
else it's okay I'm a sophomore at
Columbia College and I'm the student
from china um as you know China and
truly enjoy a very strong historical
relationship and shirley was actually
the first South American country to
recognize mainland China so my question
is what is the current cooperation
between China and Chile in terms of
political and economic cooperation and
what other steps taken that can be taken
to further these corporations it's over
here thanks so much for your time my
name is Camilla theater both my parents
are too lame but i was born in ohio my
question has more to do with human
rights and why Sheila still recognizes
some generals that have been tried and
found guilty of human rights violations
such as men way to consider next
question from this side when another
singer presente my name is Benji urban
come in de la piedra I'm a senior in the
college here I'm an American citizen but
my mother's Chilean she came here to
pursue a master's degree i'm at my
father in college here all this to say
that i've been back to chi lai a number
of times thanks to the united nations
home leave policy so i love the country
my mother is has always planned to go
back when she's retired but recently a
friend of mine who is also an american
citizen with the Chilean mother went
back to Chile and had basically they
they went to some ferragamo they rented
a car they parked the car to go see some
sights and when they came back the car
had been stripped clean everything and
it was robbed they went to the police
station the police were rather
dismissive they sort of took it as
ordinary business perhaps oh let's just
say that when I told the story to my mom
she said you know I've been watching the
news a lot
been in quincy these days and i'm
seriously reconsidering my you know
plans to move back i might just stay in
America even though that wasn't part of
what I was planning so I was wondering a
how you might respond and be if he could
just generally comment on what what
you're doing to combat crime any what's
her last question what is the matter
sigilyph tell enter my name is Babatunde
water James I'm a second year student in
the engineering school and my question
relates to the middle income trap debt
you were talking about earlier in your
presentation one the parts that you were
saying to get past middle income trap is
to alleviate poverty so my question to
you is what specific policies has your
men shave hazard initiation enacted to
reduce poverty interview thank you very
much so we have four questions yes China
human rights crime and poverty well it's
true that we have had for the last 42
years a very strong and special
relationship with china chili was the
first country to recognize china more
than 40 years ago the first country to
recognize its condition as market
economy the first country to support its
application to the World Trade
Organization and many other things and I
haven't had the chance to visit China as
a citizen of espresso and by now China
has become by far the largest trading
partner of teeth much larger than the US
or Europe and growing and not only in
terms of goods and services because now
we are entering to the face of
investments what has to be done in the
future first of all we need to to
incorporate investment and try to reach
a treaty to protect the best man in both
both in China until and to reach another
of another agreement in order to avoid
double taxation that something is being
worked right now with China but many
people were very afraid with this
with China but it has been it has proved
that in order to to compete with China
you need to be very flexible and very
active and we have a very healthy trade
with China right now and as I told you
he has become the largest trading
partner of chili and many other Latin
American design by far and we are
working on the TPP China is not part of
the TPP but eventually one day he will
become part of it and at that time that
TPP will be by far the largest free
trade zone in the world with respect to
what Camilla was asked about human
rights is very simple we had a very dark
period in terms of human rights in Chile
from nineteen seventy three to nineteen
eighty nine which was the time of the
military regime huge permanent and
unacceptable human rights violation took
place until it but after would recover
our democracy one of the main lesson
that we have learned that under no
circumstance in no place and in no time
human rights violation could be accepted
because they always have to be rejected
and people that were involved in those
human rights violation for instance you
mentioned general general Contreras he
has been judged and condemned by the
Chilean justice actually I think that
he's condemned is for more than 300
years in pieces so we think that in
order to be able to reconcile the
country we need to move forward and do
our best efforts in terms of finding
more truth and providing more justice
because that's the only way to a real
solid reconciliation within the Chilean
Society with respect to the question of
made by Benjamin well first of all tell
your mother that he is most welcome
until so maybe she had ever experienced
I can tell you something something
similar to me happen when I was in San
Francisco year ago it doesn't mean that
because of that I don't want to be here
once and and again and again so maybe
she had a bad experience we are very
concerned and very aware
that the crime and delinquency problem
in tellanon many other countries is a
very serious one and we are fighting it
with all our real commitment and
resources for insta we're increasing
substantially the size of our police
force we are changing the laws in order
to be tougher on on people that commit
this kind of primes but remember that
the first homicide was committed by Kane
and at that time there were only four
people in the Indy in the earth Aidan if
Cain and Abel and one of them committed
an AMA side and he killed his brother
Alan and therefore crime has been with
us since the beginning of our times we
have been able to reduce crime
substantial until for instance the
victimization rate which is that
percentage of household that have been
victims of crime have went down by more
than twenty-five percent in the last
three years so if your mother is really
very afraid of this tell her that three
years from now it will go down by fifty
percent and at that time I hope that you
will be able to come back to her country
without having to face those problems
and troubles at that time maybe you can
go with her and protect her because you
send her alone and that's a shame in you
finally with respect to poverty we are
you know that there are many measures of
poverty one is called extreme poverty
and the other one is called poverty
according to the world bank if you live
with less than one dollar per day you
are in extreme poverty if you live with
less than two dollars a day you are
living in poverty in Chile where
standards are much higher much higher
actually almost twice as much but we
have made a commitment to be able to
defeat extreme poverty within our
government I'm seeing here were Minister
of Social Development and you have to be
fully aware of that
because by March 2014 do we have to
answer well and we hope that we will be
able to eliminate extreme poverty until
then in terms of poverty I just was
written report that 40 million Americans
are living below the line of poverty in
this country which is one of the richest
countries in the world so it's not easy
really to accomplish this task but we
have been able to reduce poverty and we
have implemented a very revolutionary
program which is called ethical family
income which is not a typical assistant
program but is a kind of strategic
alliance between the government and the
poor families by which they receive some
support and some income transference on
the part of the government
unconditionally just because they are
poor but the rest is based on whether
they accomplish their duties for
instance if they send their kids to
school with more than ninety five
percent of assistant or if they keep
their health exams a on time and they
receive even more if they're able to
reach some goals for instant proving the
performance dedication of performer of
the kids or if they join the labor force
and this program which is called the
ethical family income is has been
designed to be able to defeat extreme
poverty in during our four-year period
and to defeat poverty before the end of
this decade and therefore for us the
country with which we are dreaming and
with which we are committed is a country
that is not only developed in terms of
per capita income but is their
development in a much more integral way
and one of the key aspect is a country
without poverty with more equality of
opportunity and that will guarantee
everybody dignity in the slide just
because they have they lived until it
and also opportunities to fulfill the
dreams and to take advantage of the
talents that's why for us
to respect of human rights under any
circumstance anytime anywhere is the key
aspect of our project and to get rid of
poverty is another key aspect of our
project and if we keep moving at the
same speed and in the same direction we
will be able to accomplish all those
goals within the next four or five years
and that means before the end of this
decade thank you very much
mr. president on behalf of Columbia
University I want to thank you first for
your efforts that have in the last
minutes resulted your better informed
than I in the signing of an agreement
between Colombia and the governor Chile
to make sure that the movement of
faculty and students back and forth
between our two countries it accelerates
I also want to thank you for your cochin
thoughtful and inspiring remarks this
afternoon I hope we will come back to
Colombia many times in the future thank
you thanks a lot
ladies and gentlemen please remain in
your seats while we escort the president
out of the building thank you